on the line dr. kanta Achmed she's a
pulmonologist and intensive care
specialist currently treating Kovac 19
patients in New York she's an associate
professor of medicine at the State
University of New York and Stony Brook
and a fellow of the American College of
Physicians as well as the American
College of Chest Physicians and a fellow
of the American Academy of Sleep
Medicine dr. akmed thanks for joining
the show really appreciate it Ben thanks
for having me and I'm now affiliated
with NYU Langone but I'll just speak
about what we're seeing in New York
generally that'd be great so what what
is happening in New York it's hard to
tell honestly from the media reports how
bad things actually are you know you're
seeing some media reports suggesting
that the hospitals are completely
overwhelmed that there's a shortage of
ventilators and medical equipment and
then you're seeing local officials say
that there is well the system is
strained that it is not broken and that
there is in fact medical equipment in
ventilators what are you saying so today
I'm speaking to you from my Hospital
which is an NYU Langone affiliate in
Nassau County where we are now having
the peak number of cases we have enough
personal protective equipment I'm
actually carrying some and I've been
using it all morning before I came to
speak to you
we have almost double if not more the
number of intensive care units when I
left work here on Thursday night we had
seven intensive care units now we have
approximately nine we normally take care
of only three that tells us that there's
a huge increase in the critically ill
and those patients are almost to the
last patient on mechanical ventilation
so that means that these patients are on
life support
needing intense monitoring all of the
time on devices to breathe we have used
all of our mechanical ventilators which
are formerly for that purpose we have
used what's called non-invasive
ventilators we have used all of those
which are converted for the purpose we
have now additional ventilators we
obtained 30 sometimes before the weekend
and some of them I'm informed have been
donated by the United States military
and they do all the work that I need
from my ventilator so there is no
patient here that is not getting
critical care to the level that they
need but this is almost 300% the usual
capacity that we see so given the the
rise in capacity that you're seeing then
the number
people who are coming in in the forecast
which is that it's going to be bad
throughout this week there's been a lot
of focus on hydroxychloroquine the
president of course has been talking
about it and Governor Cuomo you know
said that there's been anecdotal
evidence that it's working what do you
make of all the focus on
hydroxychloroquine and where do you
stand in terms of all of the talk about
whether it should be used despite the
fact that there are no mass studies of
it right great question I'm using it on
all my critically ill patient every
patient here that becomes critically ill
gets it day one through day five and the
data I know the data is from the South
of France
all it is shown is very definitive
reduction in viral load we know that the
less virus you have the less immune
response you're going to have so the
projection is that that is going to make
the injury to the lung less we don't
have the facts because we're not waiting
three years to do tests and find out
what happens we're just using it do I
know if it's making my patients better I
have no idea because the patients are
severely ill and we're giving them many
other strategies at well as well but
some of them are responding so it's not
a treatment I want to withhold and I
kind of agree with the president that
this is a drug the Plaquenil it's been
around many years for other diseases we
know its side effect profile we know its
interaction profile so the risk versus
benefit weighs out in terms of using it
for this disease because there isn't
anything else we're also using an
antibiotic called as if from Ison or
some places they exchange it with
doxycycline that cuts down on the
inflammation we know that for many other
lung diseases they're also getting high
levels of oxygen they're also getting
steroids at different points in their in
their course they're also getting immune
drugs so all of my patients I'm in an
intensive care unit today with 13
patients such as one floor above from
where I am now they are all on a
combination of these agents and they are
at the moment surviving their illness
but the public needs to understand this
is an extremely severe illness I've been
in medicine almost 30 years this is the
most severe lung injury I have seen in
my career in the quality of people right
now my youngest patient is 40 years old
last week we had a patient 36 years old
the
in patients in their 20s so nobody is
immune from this and we're praying that
the social distancing will start having
an impact we are in the beginning of the
peak now in that sexuality in New York
when it comes to the breakdown patients
you mentioned the ages of the patients
and we are hearing some cases of people
who are in their 30s in their 40s the
New York City Health Department has
released data about the nature of the
patients who are coming in they're still
disproportionately elderly and the the
studies suggest that we're still at
about around somewhere between 50 and 60
deaths in patients who did not have
pre-existing conditions what are you
seeing in terms of pre-existing
conditions and what are the pre-existing
conditions that people should be most
worried about so we're seeing a lot of
people who have diabetes a lot of people
who don't seem to have a condition but
have obesity seem to have more of a
difficult time we're seeing patients
you've got underlying health condition
you have a kid maybe they're on
immunotherapy because they are on they
have some kind of chronic malignancy
let's imagine a leukemia or a lymphoma
of that nature so there are people who
have very serious health conditions
where we are seeing this illness that
makes sense that this they could be more
vulnerable but we are also seeing
patients who have not had any
significant illness and are coming in
with the most extraordinarily degree of
severe illness so it may be was not
diagnosed them they could have
pre-diabetes we didn't know they can
have a health condition we didn't know
but this is not a benign entity and we
have had some 24 year old patients come
in in extremis
and not survive so we that those are not
my patients sighs say so we we we take
this very seriously we also want to say
we do have the most advanced critical
care and why you Lango like all of the
New York hospitals is highteeeee
interesting critical care the United
States does train doctors in critical
care to a very advanced degree our
patients are getting everything they
need there is no shortage if we had one
patient with kovat or we have a hundred
they are getting the same level of care
that we would do because we've just made
it work the
that I'm even speaking to today's I've
come out of a ten year retirement from
critical care to help because there are
not enough current critical care
specialists to do this but we do have
people that are trained and experienced
it's just the capacity and the number of
patients that's very very high and very
unusual dr. Osmond one of the questions
that's been asked is whether the the
number of cases and deaths are being
actually understated because it's
possible that a lot of people are not
coming into the hospital and when it
comes to the hospitalization statistics
by the time people get to the hospital
today tend to be more severe or people
coming in with light symptoms at this
point so asking a really smart question
I think the fact is we really don't know
what's called a case fatality rate that
means if you take a million people that
are infected how many of them will pass
away from it we don't know that because
we don't have the population study so
the mortality rates that we have are
much higher than if we had all of the
data in the background by the time
somebody is coming to a hospital they
selected it out of more severe illness
but remember I am seeing maybe one third
of the patients in the hospital who are
critically ill there are two thirds that
I will never see because they'll go to a
ward or an observation and they'll go
home because they get better and then
there's a huge quantity that don't seek
medical attention that are also getting
better so we are seeing the very sharp
edge of the tip of the iceberg but that
is also startling because the injuries
are severe to the lungs and the numbers
of these patients are very high and this
is not happening to people who have
previous lung disease and that's the
only reason or previous asthma we do
have those patients they are vulnerable
but that's not the only reason that the
people with normal lungs that are
becoming gravely ill dr. nachmann you
know there's been a lot of pressure to
move toward reopening of the economy
there's some models showing that that
the flattening of the curve has begun
there's been talk about what exactly
happens beyond the flattening of the
curve presumably the purpose of
flattening the curve was to not
overwhelm the healthcare system let's
say the god-willing we we don't actually
overwhelm the healthcare system we've
also been told that this virus could be
season could be seasonal and that it
could come
in the fall there could be a second wave
well if you were a public policy maker
right now aside from just telling people
you need to stay home shelter in place
social distance longer term after this
this curve goes down what would you be
recommending so by saying I think it's
not a good service what we should do
immediately and I have to say the
president public health instinct on this
pandemic have been exceptionally good
the travel ban on China cut down
international case transmission by 80
percent and the United States was the
first to do it and very criticized and
that has bought his time it was also
very prescient on cutting out travel
from Europe the only regret I have is he
should have done it a month sooner but
he did it and now similarly the case for
quarantine I actually believe in
something called tailored quarantine
that the president has sort of mentioned
it has been shot down in flames for I
would like to see more restriction on
certain areas where there's intense
outbreaks and less restriction on others
now that is a very difficult public
health and economic decision but I think
that that could be possible it makes
sense to open up areas the economies
where there is less population density
less evidence of outbreak less
penetrance to the virus a lot of things
that we know we don't New York there's a
34 percent punishment of the virus
according to dr. Burks which is that one
in three people that comes for testing
is infected some states is as low as
eight percent so you can use that data
to decide where to open up the economy
and also what open up the economy where
people can work remotely that should be
a priority number one and people have to
still engage in wearing face masks even
speaking can transmit this virus 50
percent of the time it's transmitted
with a schematic hand hygiene has got to
become imperative
maybe we need restaurant is off the
table
maybe we need theaters with every other
Road not occupied I mean we we just
don't know how we're going to have to
modify but we cannot stay immobilized
forever though this period that we're
doing in New York is going to have huge
dividends in the coming one to two weeks
we're going to see a relief from this
kind
tense pressure which by the way we're
handling and why you landowners handled
it incredibly well we do not have to
split a ventilator we've not had to deny
anybody care and everybody that gets on
life support gets it to the last day of
their life that is decided by their
disease process not by lack of resources
dr. kanta Achmed pulmonologist intensive
care specialist currently treating over
19 patients nyu langone in new york
really appreciate your time and really
appreciate you doing what you're doing
taking care of patients out there the
insight is terrific thank you so much
Ben thanks for reminding the public that
they have a real world role to determine
our outcome in this that's so important
what you're doing is saving lives that
we really want to be saved well I really
appreciate it thank you so much and
you're doing a lot more than most other
people are doing at this point so
appreciate thank Samantha I know that's
coming oh you too you too
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content